oh hé regardez c'est la glace
pourquoi est-ce si gros donc ne fond pas c'est en
fait vraiment intéressant comment ils font
c'est cette seule entreprise à Boston
qui oh qui est allée si vite vers le sud
Oh
[Music]
l'Ouest américain est un endroit terrible dans
temps tout ici ce n'est pas toi
veut te tuer des gens ivres en colère des
animaux affamés des hors-la-loi oh le docteur je
n'ai pas pu la sauver elle avait un médecin dissident
qu'est-ce que tu étais censé faire je
voudrais souhaiter la bienvenue à un nouveau membre dans
notre communauté
bienvenue dans notre ville géniale qu'est-ce qu'il y a avec
cette foire chaque année les gens meurent vraiment
tout le monde reste immobile les gens sont morts la
foire meurent à la foire quelqu'un et cette
fois est révolue aujourd'hui s'il vous plaît ne nous tirez pas dessus la
nuit du sexe vous avez battu ce gars lors d'une
fusillade vous '  va être un vrai héros
il est le tireur le plus vicieux du
territoire nous allons t'apprendre à
tirer
hé je commence à courir mec tu ne
devrais vraiment pas le boire cheval Aimie prépare-toi
je suis sur le point de tirer à pleine charge
sur ton  pouvez-vous n'en avez jamais vu un
oh  J'ai l'impression que je devrais avoir un morceau de
gâteau ou quelque chose ici démarrer la voiture et
c'est notre image là-bas Mila Kunis
villekulla die Jules déclare cha-cha-cha
Joe reste c'est la chaise
Oh booty
Wow tu es incroyable j'aime vraiment que
les modes les plus séduisantes  aujourd'hui
simule un gros cul si j'étais un gars noir
c'est le tour le plus méchant que vous pourriez
me jouer un million de façons de mourir en Occident
peut-être que la frontière n'est pas si mauvaise après
tout hé c'est un jeune couple adorable puis-je
vous intéresser les gens  un remède miracle
saint
[Musique]